Hi um my name [is]
Caste and I'm from Texas [I] was wondering since you all have pretty Distinct Characters
Um if You could each have like if your Characters Could have a theme song [what] Would [it] be and why, oh?
By [mice's]!
Be like Caroline's Would be I'm a Barbie girl in
A Barbie World
I don't know I think I know stephan's [I] think it's when the man Loves A woman
Who is that Michael Bolton, oh?
He write that yeah, Maybe okay Whatever I think that's [Stefan] [Song]?
Um I think [damon] [was] the Audition?
oh
Yeah that's good son wow Maybe
Some People ain't no good nick cave People People Just [Say] no good what the fuck's. [his] Name [I] [saw]
That One
That One, Look it up
Damon's Would be eye of the Tiger
And Damn Fancy damon is Camaro like going to the blood Bank I'll pissed off Cuz Stefan will Let him eat People
Matt Yaki There do you, want to trim in
You know what Let's go back to the 80s Ac/Dc. You, Shook me all night Long I like, oh?
Yeah but I think Matt has to have A love life for that Though, no I'm good over Here
Right that's genius
Thank You very much sorry you, had to ask that
Lighten The mood Down I did lighten the mood why, was the [mood] heavy what do you mean?
Hi Ian hi paul, hello, hi, we're here also I know I
so um I just want to ask you in um
What was your Inspiration?
For that sexy Look you
Make like at the Time and if you can do it for us right now
Please
Just Be sexy it's [A] very good Question I
That Look, is like a million Different Things
Mainly Conservation
Mainly
[Consequence] Debate, well When i concede this Character I wanted him to sort of be like?
Like mick Jagger Meets Brando by way of Somebody like mick Jagger or somebody Somebody like Cary
Grant Kind of Thing and so that Look is either
Did I forget my Keys?
I
Like to call my underwear Clean I like [to] call it's like A
Million [Different] Things you know what it Is in Come on it's the [Sandstorm] There's a Sandstorm Imagine a Sandstorm
Just on the Wind Blowing Sand
[That's] what it is come on?
We all do it's the Actor trick pretend you're in A Sandstorm Clint Eastwood okay by the way?
We all Came [up] with that Season one and it's a bunch of Bullshit it's not a Sandstorm it's Just wind wind I
Think it's A sans
Sans Tora
It's Amazing
Wind we're Just like Nearsighted Thank you for the Question Thank you great but it is A lot of Funny Little?
the
Synapse Firings in My Brain Is the most Random shit you Can Imagine
Hi, hi my name Is kristen I'm from Columbus. Ohio Where I'm A ceo?
so like I said I'm a zookeeper There so thank you ian for isf and all the Conservation stuff you, do
Well Thanks um my Question Is for the rest of You Guys what do you Plan on?
Doing now that the Show is done [Is] [there] Projects that you're Collecting Unemployment
Projects that You want to dedicate your Time to
I'm not gonna answer this Question yeah
Well Thankfully everybody Remains Employed until we wrap in February let's Just Try It [we're] We have Till, We have Till February?
We have the Work our Asses off um?
until then so
One of the Things that's Been Nice About the way we've Been Talking about this is you know we've all Been Together for so [Long]
And the idea that this last Season is About Bringing it all Home
We're Back in Mystic falls the the Episode Titles are all lines of Dialogue from the first Season of the Show
Where we're Revisiting?
Relationships and and ideas and and and Themes that we that We even in Events you know decade dances that
We did in The Early Seasons and so i think, we're [Gonna] Work Together to bring everything
We have to this Last Season and Knowing that it's Hard out There
It's Tough World out There
I think everyone's Really
We've Been doing this for so long now and we've learned so much and
Our Passions and our skill Sets Have been Altering you know
Directing Producing
All of Us Are Pretty much going you know
Katerina Graham it's like Writing songs at Five in the Morning and I mean Vampire Diaries Is like the ultimate Boot Camp I mean
We all Have [Worked] very very Hard and and and it's like Shooting [a] film Every eight Days
Yeah Epic Film Paul, you're out There like Selling Shows my wife and I just Started a production Company
We're doing the same thing [like] it's all very yes Boot Camp
We learned A lot Thank you Kevin Thank you julie Thank you Guys we've?
Also had These Two loving Individuals Kind of Harboring us like the real World what Is that again?
I don't understand like I read the News and Stuff but I've Been Kind of in [A] Comfort Zone
Yeah Getting by These Two lovely People so
Stepping out of The Real World and some Big-Boy Shoes in First Big Surprise
[I] will so one More Question
Hi I'm Zoe And I'm from new Zealand
Hello Hi um
I'm the Last Question so I just want to ask if You Could play Another Character Regardless of Gender
Who Would it be and why?
In the Show yeah you mean in Life or you
Mean in The Show in the [Show] I play Caroline Just Cuz She's so Bubbly I
Need some Positivity in my life Rebecca
[I] feel like I just Couldn't Play Anyone but
Carol I think I part of me Just is Caroline at the end of the day yes yes so Martha Stewart I
Play A lot let's see what it, was like to kiss me
See, if Everyone's Lying you know
See, you, Everyone like Elijah
Because
he's got Those
Wonderful Suits and he Looks so Damn good all the Time he's got that Accent yeah
Yeah That [Accents] I was laws I was Hanging out in New Zealand Look at that We brought it Home Full circle yeah I?
Can't Imagine Playing Anyone but Bonnie Honestly I
Just Love Myself too [much] I [just] shut up all
The Moment it's good that's True the great Thing About Playing some of These Characters Though
You ever
You know it's, We julie's Kind of right like it's weird out There
We're in A really weird place in the World People are Angry about A lot of Shit
and I don't know if it's like all the Pesticides or all the crazy Thanks for Watching but like When someone Cuts you off
If Someone Does send me to Me in Traffic or [something] or I'm in A bad mood
I just go to Work I can Just put it Into the Work and it's all jeff Thanks Bro
Well what's great About not Only have We become a family?
Over the Past seven Years But These Characters I think
For me Personally I feel like Caroline Feels like A sense of Home in Itself going to Work to play her
Just Feels like I'm at Home and so it's Sad [to] leave all of These great People but to
Also Say Goodbye to these Characters that you've Been A part [of] and That have
Eventually become A part of you and when life Does Imitate Art at some Points
It's yeah, it's are, We all gonna lose our Minds hi, me Mike what's Gonna happen to your hair [I've] got
No Change are you Handling [Shay] Really Concerned yeah know what to do your girl Is that Gonna Happen
I don't have to wake up at 3:00 in the Morning to do it Anymore know. What to do
All right Guys that is all of my Time, We have Guys We thank you thank you so so much love?
Thank you Thank you thank you thank you
you